the only way is up for Airbus right now  the European aircraft maker delivered  more than 600 airplanes in 2013 a record  high for the company it also took more  than twice as many orders as expected at  the start of the year good morning chief  executive Fabrice brasher was pleased  with the state of the market as well as  his company's performance they set a  target it's a fantastic achievement  which confirms first of all but the  market is a very positively orientated  second that our products are matching  ver the requirements of the airlines the  high number of sales means air bus has a  huge backlog to fill the company says it  already has enough orders to keep  production going for the next nine years